próxima pergunta qual é a explicação
para síndrome de Renault na medicina
integrativa sou sua fã muito obrigado a
síndrome de Renault é uma situação uma
condição que afeta a circulação
sanguínea especialmente os dedos das
mãos e dos pés e às vezes pega também os
lóbulos das orelhas ou a ponta do nariz
então na medicina integrativa abordagem
para entender e tratar essa situação ela
vai considerar várias dimensões vários
aspectos fatores hormonais nutricionais
estressantes e ambientais então a cim de
renô ela acontece quando os vasos
sanguíneos se contraem excessivamente em
resposta a estímulos como o frio que é
mais comum estresse ou certa substância
então isso leva uma redução do fluxo
sanguíneo para as áreas afetadas isso
causa episod de palidez de dor eem
alguns casos que a cianose que é aquela
coloração azulada nos dedos dos pés
especialmente Então os sintomas podem
ser desencadeados por mudanças bruscas
de
temperatura estresse emocional ou até
mesmo o uso de certos medicamentos então
na mesa integrativa o tratamento da C de
Renault envolve uma combinação de
estratégias para melhorar a circulação
sanguínea periférica reduzir a
inflamação equilibrar o sistema nervoso
então a gente pode utilizar aí vários
nutrientes como é o caso do ômega-3 que
vocês conhecem bem a vitamina B12 o
magnésio o potássio esses podem ajudar a
melhorar a circulação e reduzir a
inflamação temos também com enzima que
10 e os fitoterápicos né né que podem
ajudar e outra substância o caso do
gincoben L arginina e l citrina e o
norvaline que são precursores do óxido
nítrico a natoquinase picnogenol também
pode ser muito benéfico pra saúde
vascular em termos de estilo de vida tem
que ter um estilo de vida ativo
exercícios regulares isso pode ajudar a
melhorar a circulação evitar o álcool e
o fumo isso pode ajudar e fazer o
gerenciamento do stresse com Tex de
redução com meditação yoga terapia
cognitivo comportamental isso tudo pode
ajudar a minimizar os episódios de
renult e as terapias complementares na
medicina tradicional chinesa por exemplo
como acupuntura e também terapias de
biofeedback podem ser úteis para ajudar
a controlar a resposta vascular e
reduzir os sintomas e qual que é o
tratamento convencional Então embora a
medicina integrativa tem várias opções
naturais em casos mais graves É sim
necessário um tratamento convencional
com drogas com fármacos que vão dilatar
os vasos sanguíneos é o caso de
bloqueadores de canais de cálcio ou
inibidores de
fosfodiesterase em casos extremos pode
ser necessário sim uma cirurgia